is the manager
here okay this is
Israeli this is this is Israel
dates brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing de that you want to do but
we turn it into a money-making machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends I'm here in Ed Road I've been
meaning to do this video for the past
couple of weeks I was going to come with
my wife but she going to be occupied at
home so I came here by myself I'm in Ed
road I'll be going to shops of licenses
supermarkets and we will be talking
about boycotting Israeli dates uh why
because a lot of Muslim owners uh shop
owners are selling Israeli dates
knowingly and unknowingly so we just
want to go we don't want to confront
anybody we want to give out these
leaflets because it clearly tells you
what to do um and how to boycott them
and I'll be having a link of the PDF
where you guys can download it and do
the same around London please boycott
them cuz we're not going to break our
fast with the blood of our brothers and
sisters let's go and see what
happens oh is the man manager here the
manager can I speak
hellum sorry brother just giving these
out just be careful to Israeli dates
that's been S I looked up some of your
products it doesn't say where it's from
it says Jordan but here it will show you
because sometimes they change the name
and they don't write it so just just
just keep an eye please a here because
we want to break the F with our brother
and sister's
blood so I just came out one of the
supermarkets Green Valley um one thing
that is really we need to be careful to
is when I was looking at the products of
the dates the dates did not have where
they're from so one of them was like
it's Jordan yes we need to be careful to
S certain ones uh King Solomon
specifically so the ones that don't tell
you where they're coming from I took
some pictures to get information of the
company where they're selling it because
we're going to start going to
wholesalers so I looked the ones that
Iranian it's clear it says from Iran
that's fine but some of them they don't
have where it's from you look around the
box it does not have any information
from where it's from that's alarm Bells
why is he not telling you where it was
produced there some question but not we
just giving uh thing out gave to the
manager to be careful be careful inallah
but you guys need to bear this in mind
when you're going and it doesn't tell
you where it's from even if it has a
Palestinian flag even if it has Arabic
language do not buy
it
sorry just be aware of his is Israeli
dates that come into the market under
different names aldah I think those
those ones you have is okay but just
keep an
eye is the manager
here AK this is
Israeli this is this is Israeli
dates yeah this Jordan
River if you speak to the
manager I'll give you one
because manager not like this one is he
is he a Muslim yesl yeah I can tell him
not manager duai you here yeah who who's
managing the
shop tell him this is Jordan River it's
this is isra date it's over there on the
leaflet tell boy break fast with your
brothers blood the blood of your brother
and sisters
uh B just to let you know just Israeli
dates they come be careful they come
with different names sometimes it's just
to let you know yeah thank you yeah just
be careful
to brother you sell
dates
dates is the is the manager here
manager is the manager here manager no
this is Israeli dates Israeli yeah this
is Israeli give this to manager they
this Jordan Jordan River is
Israeli just be careful don't buy
boycott them just give him he can see it
from here bro names all here this is is
Israeli dates tell manager don't
buy
so guys went to Ed Road went to a lot of
of license a lot of shops uh two or
three of them had King Solomon uh medal
dates which are known to be Israeli
products I gave them nlet I've told them
about it obviously they didn't know and
we assume the best they don't know but
brother and sisters you have to boycott
your supermarket and to print these LLS
I'm going to give a PF PDF link go there
and print it and please do your bits
okay we had a US Soldier who set himself
on fire for the Palestinians nobody's
asking you to do that but at least go
off your time whatever it is and give
this out to your local supermarket and
in my next video I'm going to be going
to test goals marks dispenses and big
Supermarket branches retailers and to
show you the dates that enter there from
Israel may Allah bless you guys in and
accept it from us and like the prophet P
said if you see evil change it with your
hand and if you cannot change with your
hand with your mouth speak out against
it and the least of your mind is to hate
it in your heart we can do it with our
hands